this is the redzone eatery province and
the evidence of war is all around the UN
peacekeepers go past burned-out village
after burned-out village deserted by
terrified people who fled for their
lives we joined a Uruguayan team who are
investigating claims of a massacre
in the village of cafe it's eerily quiet
here and the peacekeepers get to work
quickly fortifying their position their
units been attacked in this area before
so they know the dangers many of cafes
citizens left DRC all together sailing
across Lake Albert to seek refuge in
Uganda the peacekeepers get a tip-off
that some of those killed may have been
buried in shallow graves on the beach
the putrid smell of decomposing flesh
means it doesn't take long the size of
the corpse suggests the victim could
have been a child this is an area that
has been the scene of a massacre and
these bodies keep on turning up sometime
afterwards we find one after the other
scattered around buried on the beach in
bushes this one is under a tree we find
four remains and body parts in just
under 15 minutes alongside the marked
graves the numbers being killed in
multiple conflicts across this huge
country seem to be far more than
estimated this is the world's largest UN
mission in a huge country with
challenging terrain but despite the
upsurge in violence here the rules of
engagement mean the peacekeepers who
can't intervene
but they work on the assumption their
presence can reassure civilians and
deter the operations of the militia in
chumbo village one of the residents
takes us to see what the militia did to
his home ok this violence has been
blamed on ethnic fighting between the
Hema and lenda tribes but in chambo
village there were at pains to stress to
us they live side by side
he's hammer and I'm Len do we want peace
we came to the market together we both
want to live in peace together to go to
the market together there are mounting
suspicions this unrest is being
politically orchestrated villagers told
the UN contingent wherewith when they
were attacked Congolese soldiers known
as FARDC just stood and watched I try to
to confirm this we find the nearest
Congolese army camp to the village the
FARDC has a poor image at home and
abroad their commander-in-chief is the
deeply unpopular President Joseph Kabila
who's under pressure to step down after
exceeding his mandate by 15 months the
peacekeepers know the soldiers the
president has absolute power over of
very much feared throughout the country
unsurprisingly the camp captain insists
they are not the problem no no there's
confusion we're the FARDC this
Fighting's between ethnic groups between
friends even brothers but we're always
neutral whatever the truth the violence
affects the young most a sick baby on
the back of his sister catches our
attention amongst a crowd of people who
fled the fighting
eight-year-old Evita tells us she her
baby sister and her five-year-old
brother have been surviving here on
their own for three weeks she doesn't
know whether their parents are still
alive they've been begging for food from
strangers
ever since the babies now utterly
dependent on a sister who's not yet
reached double figures we try to give
them our army rations but in a mass of
hungry people it causes near chaos
the pasta is nominated to take care of
the food puzzle but everyone here
everyone is malnourished and we wonder
how much of it the three abandoned
children will see Alex Crawford Sky News
in the Democratic Republic of Congo